[Music]
with ant-man and the wasp only two
months away people are starting to
wonder who exactly is the villain in the
movie if you notice in the trailers you
can hear Lois refer to the villain as
this creepy ghost and that is exactly
who the villain is and who this video is
about ghosts just a reminder about our
giveaway if you want to enter to win a
free speaker system all you have to do
is subscribe to my channel subscribe to
the stupendous waves channel leave a
like and drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero so if you are looking
in ant-man on the wasp comics for ghosts
you will not find him or should I say
her and the comics ghost is actually a
male character and is actually not an
ant-man in the wasp villain he's an Iron
Man villain and the trailer we can hear
Lois say that ghost is trying to take
over the world but in the comics ghost
is actually set on taking apart
corporations most of the time making his
target Stark Enterprises although we
don't know the true identity of ghosts
we know that he once worked for a
corporation called Omni Sapien Omni
sapient relied heavily on the inventions
that ghosts created so they hired a
woman to fall in love with him to keep
him happy however she soon died and
ghost fell into a horrible spiraling
depression in his depression ghosts
managed to create a new computer network
and managed to figure out a way to
combine his own consciousness with that
computer network once he merged his
consciousness with the computer network
he was able to find out that the woman
he fell in love with was an actor hired
by the company and they killed her after
she threatened to blackmail them
ultimately they tried to murder him too
and failed and this is where ghost is
born ghost has been busy since his first
appearance in the comics taking on the
likes of Iron Man spider-man and black
panther and trying to take down
companies such as Osborn hammer and
Parker Industries so all the ghosts
isn't an original ant-man of the wasp
villain it's pretty easy to see why they
would have him be the villain in this
movie his backstory or her backstory is
probably that she is going after
business tycoon Hank Pym again in the
trailers we hear Lois say this crazy
creepy ghost stole your tech which is
right in the alley of ghosts seeing as
she wants to destroy huge corporations
so now that you know a little bit about
ghosts and her appearance and ant-man on
the wasp let's talk a little about
abilities for starters insanely good
hacking abilities she can go through any
firewall internet security or network
that she pleases
obviously ghost is very skilled with
electronics and computers but also very
skilled with firearms and explosives and
then of course you have ghost suit which
is primarily designed for stealth
you heard Louise say that she can walk
through walls which is true and her suit
can also enable her to turn invisible
but another cool ability about the suit
is she can actually make other things
become intangible and invisible later on
in the comics after a few fights with
iron man ghost suit gets an upgrade to
enable it to mass sounds and override
electronics just by touching them which
I'm curious to see in the movie because
I'm wondering if she can override Ant
Man or the WAP suit just by touching it
I'm also curious to find out what
they'll make her origin story to be
since they stated that she stole
technology from Hank Pym I doubt that
she's tormented Stark in the past at
least in this storyline but it seems
like judging from the trailers ghosts
will have the same abilities that he has
in the comics so there's everything you
need to know about the villain and Ant
Man of the wash ghosts ghosts actually
looks really really cool in a trailer
it's making me a lot more excited to see
ant-man the wasp so that's it for this
video I want to know your thoughts on
them taking ghost 2 as an Ironman
villain and making her a villain and
ant-man on the wasp do you think it goes
well with the movie do you like it do
you hate it let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed the video hit that
thumbs up button if you don't mind and
if you'd like to stay up-to-date on
ant-man and the wasp marvel and all
other videos related to superheroes
subscribe to my channel thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
dr. PIM I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when his crazy could be ghosts
and like walks through walls and stuff
slowly otech and now supposed to take
over the world or whatever